uh so i guess my first question is what
was it like the first time that you all
got to set foot on the bridge yeah so
first time on the bridge uh was it was a
um
camera on camera test for costumes and
hair and makeup and everything
and
i'm not i wasn't sorry i wasn't a star
trek fan
but stepping onto that bridge it
suddenly made me realize how huge the
franchise is and how loved it is and i
was like you know having seen it on tv
when my brother was watching it it was
just and being in that whole costume and
i was just super
in awe of everything around me the
lights and the and you know how huge it
was and and um
and yeah i for me it was yeah incredible
experience when i stepped onto the
bridge uh
but i've been saying this because
everyone's you know definitely like you
step on and you're just like
of course they've the set design did a
wonderful job of like upgrading
the bridge that we all know you know
from the original series and from even
if you have a cursory understanding of
star trek like we know what it looks
like um but for me like i stepped on and
i'm such a
i'm such a dork about these things my
first thought was like i have to fly
this thing how do i find this thing like
bring me to my helm let me figure out
what's going on and i was just i was
like communicating with graphics people
i was communicating with people about
the way the ship was built i was
learning about engines i was youtubing
things i was googling how to fly a
starship i was like the fans will help
me um so i was just very like i took it
in and then i was like let's get to work
and so every time you see me like i
think i'm flying and i think that helps
that helps uh that helps that helps the
character for sure so that was my
thought going on to the bridge was like
how do we fly this thing yeah uh if
melissa was like the a plus student i
was definitely the class clown putting
my hands on everything touching stuff
that i had no business doing i was like
in between takes just walking around
looking at everyone's screen seeing
what's different seeing what's the same
walking on the bridge was
i come from a family of trekkies and so
i like knew very quickly of like oh this
is incredibly recognizable and my
grandma's gonna freak out uh and so it's
it's it's incredible i mean it's the
iconic bridge it's it's 1701 it's it's
that girl and so it really it was really
really incredible even every day we step
on the bridge it feels like for that for
those first few moments it feels like
that first time
and coming from a family of truckies
what is it like getting to tell them
that you're playing a horror
oh they're like
there's my my family they're like i have
family flying in so they can watch it
all together it's a it's a huge deal to
my family it's
they my family is incredibly supportive
of my career as an artist and because
they grew up watching it in the 60s like
they're like oh no we're going back to
our roots everyone's putting on footy
pajamas and
and popcorn and snacks and watching me
it it
thinking about it makes me very
emotional because i i'm excited to do
this for myself and for the fans but
most importantly i'm excited to do this
for my family excellent and then melissa
and christina you both get to uh play
new characters what are
the motivations for your characters
sure for me i'm just uh ortegas is
having a blast like she represents like
what starfleet is and that you know it's
it's highly highly competent and uh has
an immense trust in in all of her crew
um and in the adventure aspect of what
starfleet does and i think what star
trek is um and so somebody before was
saying that ortega's kind of feels
almost like an audience stand-in is that
she's having a blast um just in the same
way that the fans are and they get to
see this new character interacting with
these legacy characters and so in their
interactions you get to flesh out things
from legacy characters you didn't
realize before um and she you also get
to see her have this wonderful
camaraderie with with crew members in
different parts of the ship um which i
think is great like ritayas is the one
that you can hang out with you know like
she when she has to work she does that
really well um but she can also like
kick back have a drink and like you know
we can talk about it um and so that's
just been she's been a blast to play and
that's that's really thanks to the
writers and
the producers allowing me to infuse
myself into ortegas
excellent well thank you all so much
thank you maggie thanks
you